if you only had 10 exercises for the
rest of your life to hold on to and
build as much muscle mass as possible
what would they
be I would say that I'd have to go
muscle Group by muscle group to make
sure I check off all the boxes I I I
don't know if there's 10 muscle groups
and some of these so the caveat is these
are just my personal Spirit exercises
the ones I really like that doesn't mean
their best for everybody they can't be
and I can talk about that afterwards of
what stimulus fatigue ratio actually
means but I'd say high bar
squats why because they hit the
quadriceps and adductors and glutes very
well the amount of fatigue you get from
them is less than you would with other
types of squats like low bar squats
because until my arms got too big to
hold a bar in my back uh I fit into the
high bar position like a glove and I
love that um I fit into very few things
like a glove mostly condoms that's like
cubic centimeters left of room but um so
high bar squats I would say I would say
the over standing overhead barbell press
just cuz I'm like really good at it and
it feels great for me to do until I
guess my arms not too big I can't do
that either so that's fun is there
anything in that where the bracing the
midline bracing is good for just other
stuff generally yeah it's good for like
manhood strength like if you can
overhead press two plates for reps like
you're a serious [__] and people
shouldn't [__] with you
probably um so that's cool for that for
sure um and then I would have to say
Skull Crushers for triceps barbell skull
crusher uh how many are we at three
three um Pull-Ups for the back overhand
uh chin to
Bar why overhand no underhand uh raw
personal preference I can't rotate my
[__] in enough to do underhand anymore I
have slowly become more disabled that's
I became more jacked isn't that great
yeah there's like an ability Cur you get
better at [__] then you get worse at
[__] so uh barbell bent rose from a
deficit get two for the back bent rose
from a deficit so you stand on a little
box and you can go super deep in the
stretch and then touch your tummy and
come back any reason for doing that as
opposed to a chess supported or a seal
manhood yeah yeah you ever seen a seal
and Antarctica they're [__] pathetic
they always need to be rescued there's
babies and stuff [__] that no manhood
[__] like an orangutang would you don't
see him leaning on a [__] tree branch
all are we five deep now I think we're
five deep I haven't been keeping track I
think it's five yeah yeah five more uh
let's see what else stiff legged
deadlift for the hamstrings and you
would have hit that enough with your
bend over Rose no not even close yeah
it's isometric only with bent over Rose
you need a dynamic movement for the
hamstrings um it also hits a crapload of
your spinal directors and glutes and all
this other stuff okay six uhhuh and then
we
have um the oo yeah I have to to see the
cambered bar bench press for
chest that's the one that just like this
the Bendy tail so it allows you to press
like a Middle Ages Olden like a young
boy carrying milk yeah yeah or like a
torture device or something they put on
a bison so he goes around in a circle
and Mills Wheat or some [__] yeah okay
how you know English people have the
last name Miller cuz like that used to
be you hundreds of years
ago uh my
word um the cber bar why the camber bar
is allows you to go deeper than your own
chest level and we have lots of research
especially recently but lots of good
theoretical work before that shows us
that a deep stretch is a a pretty big
deal for hypertrophy it enhances the
amount of muscle growth you get rep
forre it also feels [__] amazing and
Ultra challenging and if you do bench
presses with a regular bar afterwards
you're like oh my God the [__] is easy
as hell cuz it's a huge partial so i'
would say I'll take an incline version
of camber bar bench as an extra at seven
yep I'll take
dips mhm in addition to that for the
lower pecs and just overall manliness
dips are sweet good amount of triceps as
well we've got long long head on the
overheads yes yep and uh what do we got
two left yeah so what we missing if
you're bothered about Abs if you're
bothered about Cals no Cavs [__] that uh
I could say something about Cavs but
[__] that have we done yeah we haven't
done side yet so I would say super ROM
laterals for side ads you literally made
your own exercise kind of a few yeah I I
need more ego [__] so let's just start
calling them Dr Mike laterals yeah Dr
Mike everything do you do you see my new
drink I came out with it's the Dr Mike
drink in any case it's where you do
dumbbell laterals but you don't stop
here you just go all the way and kind of
touch your palms together at the top can
you do that oh it used to be able to
with enough weight I can get it up there
um but then I kind of choke myself at
the top um so I'll take those for most
of the rest of the belt and I will say
the bent rows and the pull-ups take care
of the rear belt quite
well um and then I'll say
seated incline dumbbell curls for biceps
so boom like that again it's tension at
the stretch great
exercise um the shoulder press overhead
barbell press is there if I was purely
aiming for hypertrophy I would just take
it out altogether cuz it's insanely High
axial fatigue as you may suspect um and
it just really like is nothing it trains
that other exercises can't train better
but it's there because of again for the
soul and if we're doing something as
absurd as restricting oursel to 10
exercise the rest of our life I get Soul
[__] it's like what meal are you going
to eat in your last meal before they
kill you I'm not choosing macros [__]
that I'm mac and cheese but what did you
say only 10 minutes ago about it's
important to have exercises that
motivate you to do them more yes and if
you enjoy manit standing upright barbell
shoulder to overhead have at it yeah
exactly just know the trade-off now uh I
will also say here's the trade-off the
trade-off is when you go to the club and
you're standing there with your buddy
and he does more scientifically
effective exercises and there's a girl
like looking at you to and she was like
I go with your friend cuz this doubts
are like B and you're like God damn it
but Spirit energy but she doesn't know
about that uh you can't over you guess
you could overhead press your friend and
throw him away and she's like oh my God
you like such a man let's do it and by
doing I mean have sex in the middle of
the club that's what happens yes I've
seen love Island I've seen you on that
show I've seen yeah yeah yeah we'll get
back to talking to Mike in one minute
but first I need to tell you about
element element contains a science
backed electrolyte ratio of sodium
potassium and magnesium it helps to
regulate your appetite curb cravings and
improve your brain function stop having
coffee first thing in the morning
because your adenosine system that
caffeine acts on isn't active for the
first 90 minutes of the day but your
adrenal system is and salt acts on your
adrenal system so it helps you to wake
up more effectively it reduces your
caffeine consumption throughout the day
and it'll keep you hydrated best of all
there is a no BS no questions asked
refund policy so you can buy this box
100% risk-free try it drink it all and
if you don't like it they'll give you
your money back you don't even need to
return the box that's how confident they
are that you love it right now you can
get a free sample pack of all eight
flavors with your first box plus that no
questions asked refund policy by going
to the link in the description below or
heading to drink LM nt.com slod wisdom
that's drink LM nt.com
/od wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Mike you will love the full length
podcast which you can get right here go
on press it